you dad okay oh my god hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to Resident Evil 2 don't mind me looking
around like a freak for a second there
we're back with Resident Evil 2 so where
did we leave off I have no idea I'm in
the perverts room I'm in Herbert
perverts room I'm in the [ __ ] room
I'm in the douche-nozzles room I mean
the the dick mongers room the room of
the realm of [ __ ] and tits it's bad it's
not good let's read this oh I'm sure
taxidermy log please without turned out
but I'm getting tired of working on
these puny things maybe time to move on
to more challenging animals I nearly
came when I sliced a good boy eyes he's
burned it burn the game I spilled well
of wild Beezus life the specimens body
is soft sweet and white all over and
it's all mine forever
a pig oh god I wish I was dead I wish I
was dead help who are you help who are
you
nice penis oh wait what the hell I
thought that was moving four seconds
there okay there's got to be something
in this room else to discover I just
don't know what it is yet it's something
else there's a hard door but I don't
have a heart key here wow that's big
that's real big is that the Siberian
tiger that you almost kill it kill it
kill it kill it kill it dad it's fine
hello hi hello how are you good hello
I'll take that thank you hello hi Oh
bear you look happy
oh hello oh I don't have electronics
parts oh I need those and a dodo that
seems odd okay whatever this guy sure
like to collect things job letter from
your description regarding to let
chronic locking the door in the police
offices sounds like it needs replacing
power plant parts storage room clock
tower okay got it
alright so I'm about the clock tower hey
that looks like a that looks like it has
some kind of key in it hey would you
look at that I've been looking for that
forever I didn't know that it was
exclusive to the Claire part I had a
sneaking suspicion that it was exclusive
to the Claire part but I did not know
for certain okay what else is here
nothing here nothing in this hallway
it's still something in here apparently
oh but what is it is it in the blood of
one of these taxidermy --zz alright
whatever I can't find it I'm gonna put
the gratuitous amounts of gunpowder away
and I'm gonna put this way because I
don't think I need that and we're gonna
go with what we got
thus far okay so let's unlock the heart
door and see where that's gonna lead us
I'm sure it's gonna be great now I'm
really gonna be happy about whatever it
is I just the more I learn about this
guy oh no way we're here no way that's
where that door led oh that's so cool
okay good there was another heart up up
up up up upstairs okay don't know why
that was so difficult there's another
heart that was upstairs 'yes I think
yeah I definitely remember there being
something like that one of these days
I'll board some stuff up but today is
not that day
alright so somewhere in here now are you
guys still waiting on me the answers yes
the answer is very yes okay I know I
knew I knew it okay hey listen listen
how are you not going down sack of [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh I didn't want to waste that
that's not what I wanted to waste okay
whatever I guess that's how we're doing
this
kaboom alright are you dead are you just
feigning your feigning death oh okay hey
big guy
no come on okay you know what I don't
like you
oh come back where are you going why are
you hiding where didn't you just go did
that blind you did I really just blind
you or oh that's what I thought
get rack you piece of [ __ ] I just don't
like you
here's a thing about that I just do not
like you so don't even try me I
shouldn't waste those but I was just
feeling a little bit disgruntled and
when I'm feeling disgruntled I do things
that are a bit real wish but you know me
I'm always leaving the conclusions all
right um was through here first okay
that's locked that probably comes back
another way that's important to know but
I'm not really worried about it right
now
it's unlock this one I get to open all
the heart doors which I haven't seen
before so that's awfully nice hello
Oh electronic boots all right well thank
you not that not that okay can I have
this without you doing anything to me
I feel like those are the same
mannequins from the house and Resident
Evil 4 7 7 okay so there's a gear here
but I don't know if I have hmm I don't
have enough space to carry it so I'll
have to come back for it anyway
let me grab this I'm gonna go right down
to the the box again dump some stuff off
then I can come back what's over here
oh nothing good nothing good and I don't
want to go down that way because it's
probably gonna break the ladder unless
I'm not as heavy as Leon that fat ass if
he if he broke it I probably wouldn't
break it so I don't need to worry about
that at all ever for the sake of ever
okay here we go I didn't even read that
this is a chief's office okay so I got
one what I can do is I can actually drop
it off and that'll be good I need more
inventory space like real bad I need it
real bad I'm gonna go ahead and put this
in and then that'll save up one
inventory slot I don't know where it
needs to go but I'm gonna just go ahead
and use this okay so that's in and then
when I find the other one in the clock
tower which is probably the same place
that I'm gonna find it as they did
before then I'll have everything that I
need let me try to dump one more thing
off because I can't go to the clock
tower with that bad big gear so if I
don't go without the big gear then
there's no point in anything okay I've
got two keys but I need two keys I don't
have anything for this gun but I've got
bullets in there I don't have any
9-millimeter bullets but I got a lot of
gunpowder that it could make and gun
ammo for I don't want to but I do I
don't know I don't know I don't know
it's fine it's fine it's fine let's just
go ahead grab the gear let's make our
way over hopefully mr. big man isn't a
part of this experience because if he is
then I'm gonna be in trouble
I think hello okay all right I'm just
hoping that mr. big man ain't gonna be a
part of this experience that's exactly
what I don't want is mr. big man gonna
be a part of this experience also let me
see let's go ahead and see if I can go
down here I know it's probably gonna
fall again no it's Leon
big klutz okay
so I can I know how to turn that off oh
[ __ ] that's boarded why oh why why oh
[ __ ] okay hang on okay hang on hang on
everybody hold on everybody hold on no
no no no god damn it oh I didn't want to
waste another one of those all right
whatever it's fine it's fine just a
bunch of waste but it's okay who needed
those anyway nobody did not me
definitely not me Kurt chunker's Kurt
clunkers put it out we're done there and
then he's mr. big man could have come
scurrying through this is where mr. big
man comes plowing through I feel like
there was more stuff down there that I
didn't get but alas there probably was I
mean I might have to clear these guys
out I don't know if this is gonna do
next to nothing
how did you know okay so bad we had a
lot of submachine gun bullets all right
at least it knocks him down
oh just these I don't know if any of
these that all I needed now is all that
was down here alright alright whatever
I'm gonna go in and I bet the tyrants
gonna come back around because that
seems like the only way that he's gonna
be able to get over there let me go
ahead and combine this with this alright
good
let's do this what have you got mr. John
I knew it I knew it I knew it that's an
achievement apparently huh he's mad
about the Hat bang listen buddy listen
body body body body body but inscape
buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
listen you are mad for no reason and now
I have to run away from you forever but
that's okay all right what am I going
for I remember I was going for something
but I can't remember what oh there's
another heart in the records room marv
God don't surprise me like that Marv I'm
gonna have to go down the other way
through the library so I got to go a bit
of
about but it's okay wait where did oh
there he is oh he's just MP stomping
he's mad for some reason oh hey hello
hi how are you hey good to see ya I got
the diamond key for this one so let me
see if I can use this
alright what's in here can I get in here
real quick
oh yeah the portable safe but I don't
have oh okay you know what why did I
grab this big-ass piece of [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] um can I come by I can't combine
this in this no I can I just use this no
I can't I don't think I have any health
missing so I think that's why I can't
use that right now I need this I need it
real bad so I'm gonna go ahead and just
drop one of these it's fine it's just a
green herb it's fine I mean that this is
concerning sound that's a very
concerning so oh hey you're here real
soon let me I'm just gonna figure this
out real quick yeah okay I think it's
safe is very secure if it's just a
puzzle hey that's great
that's real great what I gotta do is I
gotta get downstairs into that room I
gotta put this key on there let it go
ahead and just pop a save real quick
just in case because things are getting
a little dicey in there okay just gonna
gun it oh no wait is he hang on can you
come in here I have a funny feeling you
can come in here and if he can come in
here that means I'm not actually safe
and if I'm not actually safe
imma be real best oh [ __ ] okay
so safe rooms are safe which is odd in
this environment but okay alright oh
[ __ ]
no no no no okay you're dead you dead
okay good well that's not a good sound
that's not what you want to hear that's
that's not what you want to hear okay
I'm gonna put this on the three this
time because I think one oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
why goof that oh why goofed it oh I
goofed it
oh I goofed it okay whatever I need the
other one anyway doesn't matter if I
don't have it now
um I need to get two straight here I
don't know where he is here yes here yes
records room yes yes yes in here cuz I
need this thing which is gonna help me
get across the way to the upper area
Hand Grenade yes please I don't know
what that's gonna do for me but
hopefully something good okay I will
come back for this [ __ ] later I don't
have the clover oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I don't
have room for that gunpowder oh there's
no need for that there is no need there
is no need there's no need there's no
need mr. axe if that is your real name
right so with this I can go across the
way to the library
and I can get what I need okay why you
scary piece of [ __ ] you oh my god and
it's not a cross way it's up why you
sack of [ __ ] dad scared the poopie out
of eight huh okay whatever it doesn't
matter it died I don't have a health
thing okay it doesn't matter cuz I've
lost them enough to go up to the library
and I can probably move these things
yeah oh [ __ ]
well maybe not
okay you don't mind if I do this do you
you don't mind you're busy huh you
wouldn't you wouldn't be bothered by
anything like this would you oh boy
hello that guy sure is preoccupied you
so strong ah you not strong enough whoa
[ __ ] okay I'm gonna go ring around the
Rosie we're gonna ring around this Rosie
we're gonna okay we're gonna ring around
this Rosie we're gonna ring around the
Rosie pocket full of my posies I'm gonna
delay you with one of these and I'm not
even gonna pay attention that did
nothing serves a grenade it did nothing
okay it's fine you're still eating which
is real cool real no this is not how I
wear oh god the Hamaker I am dead aren't
I I'm dead god dammit god dammit god
dammit dammit dammit dammit dammit
dammit dammit if that guy hadn't got up
from his stupid lunch break I would have
been fine what do I have in my inventory
I don't even understand who I am anymore
I'm gonna keep this health item oh [ __ ]
he was cool oh yeah I forgot about you
there we go easy peasy get this I'm
gonna do with it in the two spot this
time there we go and then 208 yeah okay
he's there that's fine
hello it's okay it's alright don't worry
about it
don't worry ah this way through here I
gotta go grab this thing again it's fine
it's all good it's great in fact it is
more than good it's it's beyond good
okay I don't have time for the grenade
hello hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy hey
buddy
okay please don't be right around this
corner again please I'm begging I was
backing Wow all right Marv don't bother
me I gotta get going I gotta get going
Marv
no [ __ ] there he is alright this does
not give me a lot of time do you know
where I am
wait does he not know oh [ __ ] he knows I
think he knows oh [ __ ]
you know if you're kind of quiet if
you're just walking around you guys
don't notice much maybe I shouldn't be
sprinting at full speed that's oh wow
this is wonderful this is new knowledge
this is new this is new and great and
wonderful I am a stealthy son of a [ __ ]
no one needs to know what I'm doing what
I'm up to
it's all good sheet apparently nobody
knows if you don't run this knows
nothing for nobody wow that is
incredible
oh they got up oh [ __ ] you're trying to
get up that ladder I don't think you
have the coordination for it wow wow wow
wow no way wow wow oh wow hello don't
mind me oh my me nothing really nothing
there's a whole lot of nothing going on
put that there that's gonna go
easy-peasy
Wow oh I need to take that big one again
Oh what was in here anything that I can
use or need or need to come back for Oh
big gunpowder I can probably take that
just yet because I got to move the
smooches around I got to move around oh
yeah do that first so once I have the
inventory space after the gears are gone
then I'll come back and get that
gunpowder but don't let me forget that
don't let me forget that if you let me
forget that then you're letting me down
which is just no good for anybody off
this bad boy in here and boom we're good
to go those gears don't exactly move at
the same rate but it's all good
nobody heard a thing all good in this
neighborhood surprisingly yes it worked
I've got so much I've got so much
gunpowder why do I have so much
gunpowder I don't know I feel bad that I
haven't used any gunpowder but you know
I've been surviving and that's what
matters
so long as I can survive that's all
that's important okay so I get that I
need this now but that they're open Rob
gone okay good
hello he doesn't suspect a thing
oh there's also a heart door over there
that's where that goes or not a heart
door probably just a regular door but
well let me then I'll take this because
I can blow past you like nobody's
business
[Music]
stupid idiot you stupid loser you
dumbass you piece of [ __ ]
oh you oh well that's not good oh I
don't like the sound of that I don't
like the sound and the proximity of
where that sticky stop is happening
nothing nothing to nobody
nuts - nobody nuts - nothin to nobody
ha ha ha this is going great
ok so I just need to go in here I need
to unlock whatever's in the storage room
I don't even know why I'm unlock in the
storage room at this point I don't even
remember the point of the storage room
was but I'm going on lock it's probably
his private pervert collection which is
always great for herbert the pervert he
always needs to get that out in the open
everybody knows this we all know this
hey I did it somehow I did it whoa I did
it
I really commentated my way through that
you're welcome for the thrilling talking
of me doing while that was happening
what did I come in here for oh hello
that's probably not good that's not a
good sign
is it Leon is it Chris Chris Leon please
don't be the chief well good to see you
again Claire we've got unfinished
business all in the neighborhood you'll
find it sharing all right for now
stupid kid if you just hadn't dropped
that [ __ ] thing I could let you go
great this sounds good you see when
you're saying that I think you're trying
to be reassuring you just come across as
really creepy oh do I get to play sherry
oh hell yeah I'm go get out of here
imma get out of here definitely most
assuredly gonna get out of here
even a kid's room as possible here the
kids were puzzles Oh what's this Oh
perfect okay
can't pull that off with my bare hands
that would be it'd be ridiculous to even
insinuate that I could do that that is
oh oh my god oh my god that's horrible
[Laughter]
to be something they got drugs what's it
got in there drugs Oh perfect a block
great okay kids need puzzles I guess
this whole town just puzzles for days oh
boy
all right I know this okay so sorry Cole
gets this square okay that's not right
okay I need how do I rotate them aha
okay they're that perfect dunzo and
dowon's Oh easy hey that's interesting
reward to give a kid when they solve a
puzzle i'ma run with this over here
snippy snippy this is so cool I mean
what else are you looking at but look
this is Oh sherry can Crouch but I
cannot this is a load of bull
what is this indeed drugs great oh good
oh good whatever that is
oh good some kind of doctor's office oh
good great good grey hello ah grave good
what great great great great okay hello
excuse me oh it looks oh this is the
orphanage isn't this the orphanage hello
hello orphanage maybe I think this might
be the orphanage a very creepy looking
orphanage
Sally's diary Wednesday are perfectly
great days cuz we get snacks and ice
cream I hate the last place I was at the
teachers were all meanies it was a
steady steady steady and there was no
ice cream I love love love it here it
was an important rule made today
everyone must write a diary get health
checkups and we aren't even allowed
outside by ourselves it's good we don't
have to go to school I don't want to go
and get picked on for my old clothes
especially but not by the guy that used
to wear them the orphanage director is
coming by today so I'm aware my most
favoritest checkered blue outfit the
director is tall the director has it
must ask the director is a policeman so
the director of the orphanage resulted
of the Chief of Police okay all right
danger no climbing whoa don't run too
late I'm gonna climb and I'm gonna run
alright too limey and then run in bow
now I now rainbow I see it now okay
scary all right good graze that bleats
gray need industrial bleach for any
orphanage everyone knows this I love
teddy bear how are you it's good to see
you I will see you again on the other
side all right goodbye
[Music]
okay oh boy boy I don't know where I'm
going but I love it oh here we go
I've already crossing I pick hello bunny
it is good to see you again I just spoke
with bear and I spoke with the beautiful
doll in my room will you be my friend
I'd be offended at the end of days
just remember stay in a wave of the
mustachioed man the man that looks like
the real-life I think marvel of the
movie
as fast as you can be free let's just
solo lead rather than all most of the
boys okay
thanks buddy yes it's really weird okay
they don't usually talk back when I talk
but all right oh hey how do I wait a
minute where's my weapons where's my
fists of fury hang on there's a raccoon
there I want to get you how do I get you
ah damn it okay well oh I see No ha ha
ha ha
apparently ok hi-yah I didn't know that
I was a hi-yah bull door well this place
looks nice if it wasn't nighttime and
creepy as hell this place would be a
lovely orphanage all the kids love it
here they get ice cream
yay there must be what about that door
that leads outside ah hello bunny ah
hello clown ah [ __ ]
key weird that they would watch your
mouth watch your language hello
alligator I remember you from Resident
Evil 7 I do I do I do
Dino I remember you guys
you were in Resident Evil 7 yes the
whole gangs here I conveniently can't
get around it
oh well guess I'll have to go through
this mysterious door over here hob ok
you don't mind me running in the halls
do you hey snake hello
[Music]
okay he likes listening to music do he
[Applause]
said of corpse Zetas Zetas corpse
that's corpses in it that's corpse is
that a dead lady that's dead lady that
is a very dead lady nowhere and
everywhere I'm a mystery no way hey
that's what you get
yeah well that's what you get okay
goodbye
off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off just like the
alligator sequence I'm not sorry for
nothing
yeah go away boom alright
scary I don't know where I'm going
help help you don't know that
Oh Oh
didn't this used to be a pathway before
apparently not anymore okay okay just
get us just gonna hide I'm hidden you'll
never find me okay cool great your face
is locked into ugly oh okay you're mad I
will not you don't know that I don't
think that it was ever gonna be any good
anyway do I got a pickpocket him I'm
gonna pickpocket you will get you must
steal them
oh [ __ ] maybe that's a bad idea ah
there's my exit oh god what listen
you're panicking a little too much kid
you don't know that that's what you get
your stupid shins Oh goodbye okay what
about over here huh oh oh that's not
good
oh that's not good you never saw me
no you never saw me
because I'm not here oh it burns what
burns what are you talking about maybe
you should go wash it off oh is Oh
perfect there you go see there you go
everything's good easy peasy
one squeeze me a hyper squeeze a lemon
squeeze got it orphanage key okay
goodbye it Terp a tray of little feets
mr. patter can't be beat
what's it what how did I not grab it but
I grabbed it what
no I grabbed it I grabbed it I thought I
grabbed it I grabbed it but I grabbed it
oh [ __ ]
he's fell out but I grabbed it I thought
like what I grabbed it I grabbed it I
literally was there and I grabbed it I
have the squeezy lemon squeeze got it oh
come on really are you are you [ __ ]
me are you [ __ ] me I had that I had
it did I not put it in my inventory or
something or what the hell this time
I've definitely got it oh [ __ ]
Oh Jett
you don't see anybody don't you anybody
I'm just gonna go for I'm not even gonna
try to lock him in by me I'm gonna go
what okay come on
oh I'm hurrying there we go easy peasy
lemon squeezy oh no oh no oh wow
oh yeah ain't good probably not good
lock it holy [ __ ]
no I don't think so I don't think so oh
I don't think so
I got more acid if you want some
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah Brody what did it put inside of him
also had that thing get in here 30
minutes oh okay earlier we've done
finished business what are you talking
about don't waste my [ __ ] time
bring me a pendant or sherry dies
pendant what do you need it for you
wanted the girl to die fine
where are you the orphanage the
orphanage where is that in the
neighborhood you'll find it
sherry alright for now I said why are
you bastard if you hurt her okay so this
mysterious pendant I guess well dammit
dammit dammit indeed damn it all where
did I get this I don't even know where I
got it oh it was on the that's right
yeah yeah just you always got so many so
many of them he's got so many permits
this guy is rich with permit all right
whatever let's see about this there's
still something else in this room
apparently that I haven't gotten I don't
know what it is but apparently there's
something so let's go ahead and save not
too many saves cuz I don't want to be a
big bubble owned baby like it told me I
was last time but just a few what else
is in this place that needs to be
unlocked with these things first floor
nothing really I left some stuff in a
few places but I think in the basement
is really where the majority of them
would be so I need to get to the
basement okay all right let's go for it
I don't know what else I need I guess I
could grab this maybe this was the thing
that it said I didn't grab yeah I was
the thing it said I didn't grab okay so
long as I got that let me dump that in
the the thing I'm a bobber a thingamabob
and there's got to be I know there's a
way to open that safe to get the other
there's there's more stuff in here that
I've forgotten about I know there is
I know there is I wish I remembered I
wish I'd looked up what the safe
combination was but I can't remember it
right now and I don't I don't know it
and I wish I did know it but I don't
know it what if I go down wait wait
there's still another way that I can go
that I haven't really gone before I
haven't gone through here and then down
I haven't gone down yet
what was down I don't even remember but
there might be something here that I
said oh [ __ ] oh hey Oh friend how you
doing you know what I'm actually gonna
preemptively just do that because I know
you're gonna bust through there and I
know it's gonna be a pain in the ass and
here we go look at this look at this I
forgot about this it wasn't even listed
on the map but maybe they aren't always
listed on the map there let me out maybe
we'll see about that buddy
hey it's not quite so devastated in here
I wonder why it was devastated in the
first place oh I wonder why please be a
little keystroke I've done it I am holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay you dude
that was not necessary in any way oh no
really that's quite a lot of quite a lot
Oh No okay that's what that was all
about
Oh No quite a lot kerfuffle first very
very little scuffle I'm alright well
what do you got what have you got
Oh gunpowder I got so much gunpowder I
don't need well let me go ahead and I'm
gonna use this cuz [ __ ] it I have so
much of that [ __ ] in it and I have so
little gunpowder they're 6 to 11 that
was it 6 to 11 mi yo homie noise oh [ __ ]
that's some thumpy oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I
shouldn't have been so loud umm acid
rounds I don't wanna I don't wanna make
I don't to make acid oh it's done it's
done I can I can drop that I can drop
this this is done ok discard that it's
done ok put that there easy-peasy
alright he's
gonna come down but you know or he's
gonna come bursting through I don't
remember what he's gonna write all right
he's ported okay so if I go dump some
stuff off again dumping stuff that I
don't need a dump but I'm dumping I dump
this I dump this I've got so much
potential for that stuff but I'm not
gonna deal with it I could get more
submachine gun rounds perfect easy
combine that boom I am rolling in it I
am rolling in it okay easy peasy lemon
squeeze me not hard all easy oh [ __ ]
that doesn't sound good
I don't like the sound of that that
doesn't sound good but that's safe and
the bag there whoa hey whoa hey whoa
whoa whoa
stranger danger whoa whoa little too
close for comfort there buddy okay I'm
gonna get I'm gonna bust this safe open
I'm gonna pop the boss this safe wide
open ain't nobody get stopped me from
getting what this safe I forget what it
was what was it I have no idea
6:00 to 11:00 that's right 6:00 to 11:00
okay nope I've ruined it already I don't
know what's in here what is in here oh
that's handy Wow that's for the gun I
don't use for all the bullets that I
don't have because I didn't get them
because I could have them but I don't do
it for some reason I don't know why cuz
I want to save onto the Gunpowder for
some stupid reason I don't know I Marv
now is not the time what did I need I
need to go to I need to go I can kill
you I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna kill
you that's fine no not in the chest in
the head in the head there we go okay so
if I go this way don't just don't even
bother and I go this way and I go in
this way that doesn't sound like a good
sound all right put this in there and
then boom bang I opened 203 not only
that I'm gonna open 102 nice
I'm open 103 perfect and I think that
was all the ones that I needed now I'm
gonna go get the extra bags oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah oh oh oh oh that doesn't sound good
more gunpowder for me more knife for me
I don't have a knife but okay there we
go
all right you [ __ ] where are you I
don't care where you are because where
you're gonna be is dead hey you want
some of this
you want some of that oh [ __ ] come on
you okay Wild West here oh [ __ ] uh
you're a problem but not that big of a
problem well like a big ugly
problem we're like a big stupid problem
we're like a big lummox you big lummox
see problem all right so now that I got
that I got more back space I'm good to
go I can go where can I go I should have
probably gotten that grenade and the
[ __ ] I can if I can get that yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna ring them around my
Rosie
yeah that sounds sexual he's gonna go
ringing round Rosie's Marv is gonna stay
out of my way I'm gonna go back down
that way no I'm gonna go that way cuz I
need to ring around the Rosie Omar's no
Marv Marv no Marv no goddamnit okay long
way around it's okay I'm not worried
about this this is fine they're goddamn
lictors you son of a [ __ ] you better be
dead you dead okay oh my god come on oh
you made me waste my ammo you made me
waste my ammo you sack of [ __ ] I hate
you so much
where did you come from Oh screw both of
you yeah he has my knife no god dammit
god dammit god dammit god dammit why
didn't that close up the stupid things I
need this knife I need this who's there
who are you stop being you okay go
no no no no no no put that put that
thing in the foot that's the foot that
oh okay all rights go hi friend
look at you oh you're so cute except
you're not and go away thank you oh my
god this has not been worth it just to
get gunpowder and a frickin grenade I've
wasted all of this ammo I did not need
to do this in any way shape or form I am
a fool
I'm a big fool I am an idiot I'm a big
idiot fool I'm a foolish idiot big I'm a
big idiot I wasted like three clips Oh
God hello who's there knock-knock go
away I am an idiot I'm an idiot and a
fool and a foolish idiot and a grenade
and a grenade I was no point in doing
any of this dive lost so much respect
for myself I've lost I think I spent a
hundred bullets a hundred SMG bullets a
hundred 100 wha why are you still alive
how are you still alive and why are you
still alive these guys I swear they up
the difficulty on this like in between
the last now okay alright just gotta get
back to the chief's room all of that was
not worth it I was worth it getting up
to the bag but then I went the wrong way
to eat the other stuff which I shouldn't
I'm going the wrong way now I shouldn't
have done that was my bad I am a fool I
know this I understand this but my god I
am ok whatever it's fine it's fine you
know why it's fine because it just is
and I have no other reasoning besides
that but it is fine it is 100% fine
so let's get back into the Chiefs room
and then we can go from there all right
so the jmb combine this with that
suddenly it's an extended jmb I am NOT
getting any more ammo for this this gun
so I kind of have to go for this gun
which is fine cuz it's a good gun and
I've got all of this gunpowder but I
don't want to spend it for some reason
my brain is like don't spend the
Gunpowder rule number one of survival in
the apocalypse don't spend your
gunpowder you did it's not gonna make
Big Bang II bullets so you can't use it
if it doesn't make Big Bang II bullets
then there's no point in using it right
am i right high five if I'm right BAM
I'm right everybody knows this everybody
loves this everybody loves me everybody
knows me I'm right I'm 100% right I'm
not gonna use my I'm not gonna use my
gunpowder I don't care I'm not doing it
it's it's impossible I want to sit on it
I want to I want to look at it I want to
appreciate it for what it is I want to
just smell it sometimes I want to paint
a picture of it I want to sleep naked
with it I want to bathe with it
I'll just get a bathtub full of
gunpowder and I want to dip myself in it
light some candles risk death you know I
like the adrenaline rush I'm fine by the
way I'm fine everybody I'm fine you guys
are wondering if I'm not fine I don't
know why you're all so scared of how
fine I am
maybe you're intimidated by my but my
finest because I am incredibly fine
that's what I am and how I'll stay so
thank you for asking actually but no
thank you for nosing yourself in my
business okay let's go in here I think
in the firing range
there was another diamond door hello hey
how you doing yeah here yeah okay this
might be the last diamond door so let's
see if it was it was get rid of that
[ __ ] get it out of here all right what
was in here great love it
loving it love it in I think it's great
3f Locker oh yeah that's how you get the
locker oh oh [ __ ]
um listen buds but in ski no one's in
here don't know what you're talking
about
well I suck
come on Wow there we go there we go okay
get out of my way who had my knife you
have my knife guy my knife back thank
you little bloody but that's okay
alright did I get everything that I
needed in here is everything in here yes
everything's cleared out of here I'm
good there
I could go develop this film I could I
could do that but I don't want to
because whatever's in that locker is
definitely not gonna be worth going all
the way back in developing this
I've gotta go develop the film and I'm
gonna go back I'm gonna do it I just
have to do it I've been the just such a
[ __ ] I'm such a [ __ ] why don't I go get
all this stuff in here first then I can
go back to the deposit box and I'd feel
a lot better about myself and then I
wouldn't have to go through that again
and then it'd just be a straight shot
outside right cuz I've got the inventory
space so no why not utilize that that
makes sense well that makes sense that
makes a lot of sense
are you dead you better be dead are you
dead up there yeah exactly there's blue
flowers all over the place you guys know
how valuable blue flowers are okay so
there's this stuff left in the morgue I
don't know if there's any lictors alive
I think I killed them all which is
totally badass of me and totally awesome
oh hello there we go alright so what
else was here I don't even remember I
got I'm just gonna open them all nothing
oh there we go okay I have now gotten
everything so I'm very proud of myself
for getting everything okay yes I'm
going back up to the guys office which
is fine totally legitimate use of my
time and then I'm going to go develop
the film and then I'm going to go see
what's in the film and you know that's
okay because it's not a waste of time
because I just for some reason I'm very
completionist about this and that's fine
a lot of people can be completion is
about everything and that doesn't mean
that I'm weird okay the good news is
I've probably killed all of the baddie
in the immediate area so I don't need to
face any more because they're all dead
right that's definitely the circumstance
that I'm heading towards probably okay
I've made it all the way over here this
is gonna be so worth it when I find out
what's in that locker let's go baby DCM
ah DCM it was way away from what I
thought it was DCM baby
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] um deceive this is gonna
make all what about what's about to
happen to me better okay I owe your your
oh there was bullets you know hey you've
got my knife don't don't dodge my
bullets give me that I'll take that
knife you don't have my knife anymore
great you know what I didn't want it
anyway didn't want it anyway that's
gunpowder in there stuff in the main
hall why not you know what let's go for
it baby
let's click I am a completionist so
let's do this let's do this right yeah
baby I'm here I might as well yeah why
wouldn't I why wouldn't I anything in
the Stars office no duh yeah why would
there be blue stupid idiots
everybody's dumb except for me anything
else in there no boom how give me that
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay you know you yeah
what else is in here oh yeah I'm they're
like bullets find one of these like
bullets back here or something yeah
bullets all right I don't know where mr.
X is but he's not here I may have to
shoot them to get these bullets that I'm
going for but whatever it's all good
I can actually what I'll do is I if they
grab me hello
don't grab me okay it was fine it was
fine if they were gonna grab me I was
gonna knife him okay and with that I
think we are for the most part dunzo
ones Oh oh yeah there's spray in the
bathroom but I'm not worried about that
there's something in the East office but
I'm not worried about that either I'm
kind of curious
what do they leave in the East office no
Marv
ah that's Andy okay that's actually
important I leave anything in the art
room I forgot about that
in the art room okay I think I'm good I
think I got everything I think I got
everything
Hey look at my back everything's good
everything's good great everything's
great so I just get back and now I go
downstairs I've got so many supplies I'm
very happy about everything that I got
and everything's great so now that
everything's great
I can go away forever
great good everything's good I've got
everything I need
see you downstairs okay and with barely
a 10-minute delay I have now fetched
everything that I possibly could and
there's nothing else than I need to know
that door is probably locked forever
maybe I should try it just in case I
don't think there's any reason that I
would go down there because the guy with
the parking permit isn't who I need to
talk to so this is definitely a lock
there was no point in going over there
the big red light should have probably
been an indicator but I'm not one for
reading signs so let's go through this
bad boy and let's finally make our way
outside Oh baby boom baby
Oh Oh what what hey whoa hey whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa hey whoa whoa listen
buddy listen I'm just gonna go I'm real
good at running circles around you you
kind of suck a little no no no no don't
go there
oh don't go no faster come on now 4:30
a little need to do okay no no no no no
no
oh no oh no no no no no hey how you
doing I do I don't want to go that way I
want to go in the gun shop cuz I know
the gun shop and I'm aware of the gun
shop looks like what's the other way oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] hey where'd your
hat go you nerd oh [ __ ]
oh well that was convenient okay Greg
goodbye alright yeah apparently okay
it's a different way than I was used to
going before but I'm assuming it's gonna
have the same result oh that's the sad
place
you still there buddy apparently not
where am I going
that's right I guess I am going to a
completely different place no you don't
see nothing listen there's nothing here
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
okay listen you're about to get knifed
no what the hell what what the hell you
were about to get knifed oh come on you
can't knife him on the stairs cuz I fall
over like a little baby
oh yeah well alright whatever screw you
no no no that's what you get stupid dog
didn't even know those door here oh [ __ ]
alright come on come on
[Applause]
sorry bud had to happen had to be that
way nothing I can do about it you know
how it be is that the orphanage
why does this look like looks like the
evil within to here but I'm not gonna
worry about that
it's links links links points goings
there we go
okay we're good I thought I heard
footsteps off to the side but it's all
good hello Sookie
hello I see an herb hey bud how you
doing wind oh yes please I love when
they give me so machine gun ammo that is
very nice ah no and no and no and no and
no and one down and two down there we go
who down easy-peasy no casualties
all right oh hello oh [ __ ]
close that for me thanks alright I hate
doing that but my god do I appreciate
their being offensive between the two of
us that makes my life so much easier
alright there's something hidden amongst
the road here know something over here
maybe I there it is blue herb got it is
that the only thing over here apparently
not but it's probably on the bus here
this doesn't look good
I don't trust this
there we go
said grenade sweet hello Poochie
oh there's a fun game we're playing here
but uh hoping that maybe it could what
no oh come on
how many Wow aggressive I'm just gonna
go for it
one where their tour was it just the one
okay handled pretty nicely I'd say I
said I'd sanded pretty good there oh no
really
raccoon city orphanage oh god oh god bad
I don't want to question the artistic
integrity of some children but my god
they need to learn some depth perception
because wow that is horrifying okay I
was gently approaching her I was there's
some dissonance of action here
I was gently approaching I was not being
like that I was not the way that that
was yeah hang on Cherie I'm on the way
time to kick ass and take some names
time to name some ass and kick some
takes I'm gonna get him why are their
graves in front of the orphanage oh oh
hello
well mr. bunny have you seen anybody
here you oughta watch out for the bad
every recipe delicious don't feel bad
okay thank you buddy I your really feel
like your improv skills need some work
there alright so I know where oh that's
right I just came here to willingly hand
over a pendant
okay well that was handy oh whoa hey how
are you still standing it's my fault
[Music]
yeah
where'd that thing go friggin
chestburster what a ripoff of aliens
what a ripoff this whole this whole
thing's a ripoff what a rip oh hey how's
it going there diary blanks diary if
you're reaping dis go call police
boogeyman's here eating every ball be
many bark boogeyman's
helped they're coming help me Mom
supposed to be hilarious bark boogie but
everyone's so afraid of bark apply you
know the bark boogeyman oh [ __ ] okay who
killed markiplier
okay alright then well this seems
precarious oh that's that's a thing okay
goodbye everybody else I I can't even
control it it's just gonna go okay oh it
is Resident Evil 7 I detect some reused
assets Shari Shari Barry hi Shari
hi sherry are you doing uh alright new
we don't need words for this moment I
suppose it's just good to stare alright
anyway I'll go around oh [ __ ]
oh go why
okay go go go yeah go go there's a
problem happening
I know it's behind me I saw is there any
items here sorry I just have to look for
items you know how it is I'm hurrying
good thing that guy doesn't know how to
run oh [ __ ] I should probably look where
I'm going any items here now okay
alright get in the lift
get in in the lift hey it's this is
where the picture comes from hello oh
[Music]
wow that's impressive
oh hi second head Oh God
the Oh God is right holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
did he take out the tyrant mr. X mr. X
did you take him out probably not
probably not dead probably not gone
forever probably fine probably okay
probably okay something tells me that Oh
oh hi hey how you doing that's
surprising considering how many times
I've been bit sure sure sure he's fine
do you know Sharia impressive display of
drinks what happened to her we have to
assess the situation who are you I'm
Claire
didn't foresee this excuse me where is
she
hello what
Oh Annette tell me what happened to
William I don't know is that the
creature responsible for this
can you help me find Shari are you going
look I don't have time for 20 questions
everything's under control okay yeah
okay good talk thank you thank you
good talk great very very happy about
how that went down feel good
anyway this items in here my item senses
are tingling so I'm just gonna scout
around for the eye ah ha now that is
what I am talking about that is what I
often talk about and refer to oh that I
don't think I want to go that way do I
I'm going that way here I go whoa Boesky
this eye that felt final that felt final
why damn it yeah I did now damn it I
didn't more can I go up ah [ __ ]
yeah I wanted him the door was probably
locked anyway it wasn't it was in the DA
there's something in the office yeah I'm
probably gonna come back to its place
fine it's probably affected no I'm not
ever gonna come back to it oh god damn
it I reach the load Gabe I auto here we
go
oh [ __ ] oh god damn it oh [ __ ]
I'll be back I'm back let's see what's
going on it was open I should have no
high-powered round about gee okay I knew
about G but this definitely locked okay
so all I missed out on was a little room
and a place to save that's pretty much
missed out on but that's okay because
that's enough to make me go crazy and
out of my mind that's that's all it
takes
I go nuts oh that's all it took I needed
to save anyway it's alright
it's fine did I get everything great
okay I'll get everything in here again
where did sherry go you know I don't
know I don't know okay now that we got
everything now we can go down it was
literally I don't know why I restarted
that whole thing just to do that but
I've done I've done more for less
to be perfectly a super oh you're always
so full of pepper
I didn't put my herbs in there yeah [ __ ]
okay who's in here whose big big honkin
monsters those monsters were big in
honking oh hello yeah yep still gross
still gross but I feel like I'm down
here with a lot less purpose than I was
before with Leon it was like I just
incidentally fell down here I also
apparently there's something else that I
missed in there that's okay I'm not
worried about PO just a tea bar oh okay
so I'm here all right
yeah cable car yeah fancy yeah who don't
who defunct who'da thunk 'old that Oh do
I gotta solve the chest puzzle again I
know how the chest puzzle goes and I
know where the chess pieces are whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay um
all right first things first
no yeah fall over each other why don't
you I wish I had a shotgun
there was something in the yeah that's
right
Oh what was your code what was your code
ah
what was your code were you suck I don't
remember it don't get back up all right
I'll come back for you please don't fall
down there I go Here I am
hello what a good mom something tells me
that less of a mom more of an experiment
supervisor because I think series
probably some part of this horrible
experiment gone so right so very right
so incredibly right there's one thing
that I can tell about this entire
endeavor of this things have gone good
okay so the plugs are the same
definitely I'm gonna swap out for the
other gun because I think I have some
kind of ammo for it so I'm gonna swap
this out and put this right there put
this here and now I've got some bigger
boomers with which to boom my way
through whatever it is that I need I've
got so much
[Laughter]
but that's okay does being mad is part
of survival you gotta be mad at the
world around you if you're gonna
persevere and make your way through to
survive in this world you gotta be mad
you got to get mad and you gotta you
gotta grit your teeth and not quiver at
the sight of death that faces you that's
what you have to do that's what you
always have to do what is this Oh
pamphlet yeah yeah okay all right let's
save and let's giddyup that's the only
save we're gonna do in the sewer because
I'm about to blast through this faster
than you've ever seen anyone blast
through everything anything anywhere
understood you get me you get me you
guys get me oh the safe that's right
this is safe there and I read herb then
safe then blasting through this harder
than anybody has ever blasted through
anything ever forever and a day
Ariella there's stuff down here
apparently hey a t-bar hey that's that's
good I need that loot Leonce note Claire
if you've made it this far you're almost
out of the city I've gotta take care of
something before I leave but I need to
tell you something case I don't make it
this is all umbrellas doing let the
people know oh well thanks Leon that's
awfully noble of you
you couldn't have left me with like ammo
this time which you did last time that
was kind of nice uh heat-resistant safe
I know about this safe all right that's
everything down here all right so go get
this safe done and then we'll get out of
her way am i injured I'm a little
injured I don't remember when I got
injured but probably during my many runs
through the house that were completely
unnecessary and didn't reward me with
nearly as much as I put into it so
there's that then hello whoo you look
fun
Wow you look really fun I'm just gonna
I'm kind of shocked by that all right I
need to dump some stuff in the vault
before I carry on because that's how
this game works and I tend to forget
that sometimes put is okay
you know it's not really necessary but
then I do it anyway because I am just a
giant cook okay get this out combine
this with this there we go that looks
impressive
okay store that now that takes heavy
bullets but I'm not worried about that
you use the high-grade gunpowder because
my rules are very arbitrary no don't
store that take that out put this away
and we're going to go okay let's do this
baby let's go now we're going we weren't
before but now we're going okay who's
here
where am I going I've already gone the
wrong way but that's okay what's in here
nothing okay oh hey hi Oh howdy hey
listen you guys suck but you know that's
not your fault you were just made that
way whatever there's a special spot that
you go wow whoa yo that is a little too
energetic for my tastes my bros my bros
my bros don't do that
alright good great great good there is
some goodies around the corner here I
know as in goodies I mean a grenade
apparently I wish I had my shotgun that
was really real cool I don't know I'm
not going anymore so real cool so if I
open up this I think I have the tool for
this this should lead me to the scary
area which I may go to first if I go to
that forced then I wouldn't have to
worry about what's getting the pawn
pieces but I don't exactly have a big
enough slot for the stuff that I need
for that choices suck alright I'm gonna
go for it
cuz I did it last last time and that
really didn't work out too good for me
alright hello oh that's nice another
thing to back you up inventory I didn't
need to get it right now I could've
gotten it later but I got it now so you
know there's that alright let's go for
this
only a little bit oh boy that's that's
fun don't like that I don't remember
them being nearly as noisy as that I
don't remember that being super noisy
well I've got a grenade so I should be
able to take care of it
this grenade let's do this baby
[Music]
where'd you go come on back come back
where'd you go oh no I don't think that
one's gonna go away very creepy sounding
I don't remember is sounding this creepy
last time but easy easy gubbins oh boy
yeah don't mind me yeah don't mind me at
all oh I think it knows where yet I
can't see yeah well I've got flame does
good to you guys
Oh
okay that took a little more gubbins and
I was hoping for it but I got a lot of
grenades in my pouch that I haven't been
using them because I didn't think I was
gonna go here right away but here I am
oh is that hamro that's AMRO all right
bottom waterway okay great good
ah that's all that was here all the gift
I need you know that really is the gift
that keeps on giving
so yeah you still come out of there
don't you oh good your eyes already
exposed that helps that doesn't need
help all right can you
oh yeah see you don't actually need to
fight you can just follow oh hi you are
not supposed to be here
there you go good shots me thanks me I
really appreciate it
I worked real hard still are you kidding
about you getting back up okay whatever
you suck I don't care hello hi how you
doing my name is markiplier what have
you got here for me
good stuff hopefully good great God you
are so nice to me and everything that
you give me hello can I have what I came
for and nothing else you suck yeah
you're not gonna give me this done yeah
yeah be scary why don't you okay so I
take I dig this out of y'all not that
I've got a lot of space for this hi I
guess can I shoot you through this I can
Oh No there you go
that's what you get um King piece I
don't have the King piece just yet but
I'll get the King piece up here and then
I'm good to go
don't all right where did you come from
where where did you come from
whoa hey no no not that one whoa [ __ ]
you trip that was your own fault that
was bad for you bad for business
shouldn't have done that stupid idiot
what is that what is that what Oh what
is Oh what is that I don't know what
that is but I love it oh my god
that a lightning it's a Taser who's
still alive here who else to get tased
ya gotta try it out I'm not gonna okay
okay all right you know what I am NOT
opposed to that that is okay in my and
bada-bing bada-boom
I've got everything all right and your
dad all right
I love this new gun this gun is great I
think it's the best gun I think all
other guns are stupid by comparison to
this great gun
I left blue in there goddamn it I can't
go get that can I
because that's very far away no it's not
it's right yes I can't get that oh yeah
I can combined with that perfect perfect
I'll use that Green if I need to if I
like there's something I need to carry
else besides what I've got so far I'll
use it but for now I'm very happy I am
quite happy actually Lebowski hello oh
oh yeah yeah uh-huh uh-huh
yeah oh yeah yeah Oh tell me more
all right good talk buddy
good talk very happy about that I love
this gun this gun this gun is the
greatest gun that ever gotten do I think
I got everything I need in here all
right we're good to go
we got the pieces let's go drop hello
okay
another person wants to have a
conversation I guess hey listen wow you
look so fabulous all right cool goodbye
let's talk oh you too all right and what
is that gonna do to you shot those
things I've been wasting it on normal
zombo's what are you kidding me I have
an idiot I thinking one shot those
things what let's bro I'm probably never
gonna get more ammo for this thing in my
life
Oh Sees best but I've wasted bullets
that's okay it felt good it felt real
good yeah I'm a fool but hey I'm a happy
fool that's a lot okay I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna waste anything on you I never
waste a thing me waste ammo what who are
you to disgrace me in such a way I can't
believe you
I can't believe you I can't believe that
you would say something to me like that
like Do You Know Who I am no I don't
think you do I don't think you
understand who I'm going to put this
thing away because I shouldn't have it
it to be perfectly honest if it's in my
inventory I'm gonna use it and I want to
hold onto it for safekeeping for later
so I'm just going to put it away I just
need two more pieces I think I know
where they are but this way I eventually
need to use that but I'm not
alright let's save that that was good
progress I know I said that was the only
say if I was gonna do but I lied because
I do that sometimes when I'm playing
this game alright let's go we got more
to do I'm running a little low on ammo
but I'm okay only I had some kind of
thing that I could make a meal out of
but I just don't I just you know I just
don't there's just not enough in this
world to supply me with that oh well you
know mmm c'est la vie
anyway let's go over here let's see
what's oh [ __ ] oh I really could use
that gun ah I really should would I wish
I had that gun now god I'm gonna
ah god damn it okay alright here we go
alright
old-fashioned way love this
alright kind of forgot about that but
that's okay I got enough to kill one
more of those things in pretty much
nothing else so that's great
I'm very happy about that this is going
great
listen I don't need that gun I was doing
fine without that gun before so I don't
know why you think I need that gun now
cuz I don't that's the thing that's the
thing that you guys are seem to be
forgetting I I don't need the gun
I don't what I need is self-control I
don't have self-control so I need to
exercise that because if I don't have
self-control that I'm never gonna be
able to earn that gun is the thing
that's what you all seem to be
forgetting I need to earn it I need to
really feel like I earned it see I'm
getting mo anyway it's all good
what does that roll-film for a hiding
place oh yeah oh yeah yes yeah I forgot
about the hiding place thing yes right
okay but this is good this is fine did I
get everything in there yeah I did whoa
hey how you doing I'm gonna just I'm not
gonna oh whoa okay all right listen [ __ ]
there Sonny by me [ __ ] okay hang on oh
boy this is a problem
oh boy okay let me unlock this this is a
bit of a bit this is a bit of a problem
there's a bit of a problem bit of a
problem what is this can I have this
please a gun powder a useless useless
gunpowder was this gonna there we go
bullets now that's what I'm talking
about now that is what I'm referring to
Oh szf that's right szf that was it okay
where does this go I forget where this
goes yeah this connects back this
connects back this connects back I don't
need to go back but I'm kind of just
opening up the possibility of going back
that's right it connects back to the to
the place so that I can get whatever the
quote-unquote hiding place thing was
I'll take that but I guess what I could
do what I could do since the tyrants you
know not since the tyrants all dead and
all definitely 100% dead I guess I could
go develop this film go get the two
goodies because I remember one of those
goodies was actually pretty good
so if I can go get the goodies that
might not this one not this one this is
not the one that I was talking about so
if I go get those goodies that's
actually gonna be pretty Duty for me so
I just got to go get the goodies sound
oh go get the goodies I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go get the goodies I'm just gonna
go get the goodies Marvin you're not
Marvin you are Marvin
excuse me Marvin no okay and where was
it was in the Stars office but I don't
think you can get these until you get to
Stars office and then the lobby that's
right starve office and then eartha the
press room whatever it was all right be
something good be some good good a box
perfect I love boxes boxes are the best
I don't have enough ammo to really take
it into that right now but someday I
might I might someday yeah
I'll be able to kill liquor and one one
fell swoop all right that's good I like
that
now what's the other thing it better be
equally as good
I can't wait to discover what that thing
is all right three two one what is it I
forget hey what is that oh it's ammo for
the spark shot oh hey buddy yes yes yes
yes
I can go get this board totally useful
to get this board but I'm gonna do it
here I go nope nevermind arrow there I
go I got a board yeah the final board
yeah that's everything I think that's
everything in the entire place okay but
that's good I've got everything and I've
got ammo and I'm good to go and I'm so
happy
okay so put that in there I'll reload
that later put this in there I'll put
that somewhere I guess I don't know
probably not okay but this is good this
is good real good
it doesn't seem good but trust me it's
really good so I am all out of time for
this episode but in the next episode I'm
gonna crank through the sewers faster
than you've ever seen anybody crank
through anything ever so look forward to
that so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down the comments below and as always
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]